foreign
so much
and maybe
maybe if you open yourself up to it
there's a possibility I don't think so
Quinn
quell
I don't think so well what I'm trying to
say Peter you know this is an open line
right what we're listening to everything
you're saying and it is painful and
you're just telling me now we were
hoping I would stop on its own but I
switched it over to private what color
button did you push blue for the blue
suit oh no blue was the Open Line for
everyone orange is for blue what black
is for orange yellow is for green green
is for red and red is for yellow no
yellow is for yellow green is for red
red is for green I don't think so try it
then
oh
you're right